depuis 60 ans et petit panneau jaune qui
fleurissent aux entrées de nos communes
sont toujours autant convoité en 2018
dans les yvelines 63 communes ont été
labellisés villes et villages fleuris 18
chaque année on en a quelques-unes
supplémentaire et on voit une
participation plus en plus importante
pour ses 60 printemps le label s'est
refait une petite beauté
mais ces objectifs n'ont pas changé il
garantit les démarches d'amélioration du
cadre de vie et renforce les qualités
d'attractivité des communes donc je joue
plus la quantité de fleurs mais nous
avons une grille d'évaluation
transversale qui récompense en fait une
stratégie vertueuse des espaces verts
une volonté politique
le jury composé d'une vingtaine de
membres a parcouru l'été dernier
l'ensemble du département
fontenay-le-fleury par exemple a obtenu
sa troisième fleur dans les yvelines
seules trois villes ont de nouveau
décroché le graal à savoir quatre fleurs
c'est le cas du vésinet une habitude
depuis 1992 tout est possible aussi avec
avec une participation aussi de
l'urbanisme une participation des élus
sans leur application et l'implication
des services techniques pour pourraient
pas obtenir ou garder les quatre fleurs
qui sont quand même une valorisation de
qualité de vie sains
un label qui encourage le renforcement
de la nature en ville pour découvrir les
bonnes pratiques déjà mises en place aux
quatre coins du département des visites
sont organisées tout au long de l'année
c'est destiné aux élus des qui sont en
charge de ce sujet développement durable
nature en ville etc destinée aussi aux
jardiniers des espaces verts des
communes yvelinoise les inscriptions
pour le label 2019 ouvriront en avril
prochain